♪♪
>>> WELL, ALL GOOD THINGS MUST
COME TO AN END, INCLUDING THIS
PROM.
BUT WE'VE GOT A COUPLE SONGS
LEFT.
SO LET'S MAKE THEM COUNT.
CLASS OF 2002, HOW Y'ALL
FEELING?
♪♪
>> HARD TO BELIEVE IT'S BEEN
20 YEARS SINCE THAT NIGHT.
AFTER GRADUATION, WE ALL WENT
OUR SEPARATE WAYS, BUT I STILL
LIKE TO THINK ABOUT MY OLD
FRIENDS AND SMILE.
SHELLY HINES GRADUATED FIRST IN
OUR CLASS, THEN WENT TO HARVARD,
WHERE SHE GRADUATED DEAD LAST.
I GUESS OUR HIGH SCHOOL JUST
WASN'T THAT GOOD.
TESSA WHITE GOT MARRIED AND HAD
TWO BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTERS.
AND ONE FAT UGLY SON.
AS FOR RACHEL FINSTER, WELL, THE
LESS SAID ABOUT HER THE BETTER.
DANA MIGUEL MADE GOOD ON HER
PROMISE TO HIKE THE APPALACHIAN
TRAIL.
SHE REMAINS MISSING TO THIS DAY.
TRENA DASH PLAYED D-1 SOCCER IN
COLLEGE AND WON A NATIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP.
SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN HAPPY, BUT
SHE NEVER GOT OVER RACHEL
FINSTER SLEEPING WITH HER DAD.
DARIUS CALDWELL EVENTUALLY MADE
IT TO THE PROS --
PROFESSIONAL PORNOGRAPHY.
HE'S WORKED WITH ALL THE GREATS,
EVEN RACHEL FINSTER.
>> AS FOR CARLY HILL, SHE MOVED
TO WEST VIRGINIA AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL AND MARRY A MINER, A COAL
MINER WHO WAS 16 YEARS OLD.
BILLY MANDEL FOLLOWED HIS
DREAMS.
UNFORTUNATELY, HE ONLY DREAMED
ABOUT KILLING HIS GRANDPARENTS.
DOUGIE FINNEGAN NEVER STOPPED
INVENTING THINGS, AND EVENTUALLY
ONE OF THOSE INVENTIONS MADE HIM
RICH.
FENTANYL.
MAYBE YOU HEARD OF IT?
RACHEL FINSTER SURE HAS.
CLASS SWEETHEARTS BECCA AND
ROBBIE MADE A VOW TO LOSE THEIR
VIRGINITY THAT NIGHT.
AND THEY BOTH DID.
TO THE DEEJAY.
SOME PEOPLE HAD HAPPIER STORIES,
LIKE NATALIE TURNER, WHO WAS
GRANTED THE FIRST GAY MARRIAGE
LICENSE IN THE STATE.
WE ALL WENT TO THE WEDDING, EVEN
RACHEL FINSTER, WHO WAS THERE
PROTESTING WITH HER HATEFUL
CHURCH.
SEVEN YEARS LATER, JEFF AHMED
REACHED OUT TO RACHEL TO TRY TO
TALK SENSE AND HER, AND IT
WORKED.
THEY STARTED DATING AND MOVED IN
TOGETHER.
HIS BODY WAS NEVER FOUND.
SOME OF OUR FRIENDS SURPRISED
US.
CARLA ANDRETTI FOLLOWED HER
MOTHER'S FOOTSTEPS ALL THE WAY
TO THE CAPITOL BUILDING, ON
JANUARY 6th.
HOW CAN WE FORGET AMY FULTON?
I'M NOT SURE HOW, BUT WE ALL
DID.
JUST COMPLETELY FORGOT ABOUT HER
LIKE SHE DIDN'T EXIST.
THEN THERE'S PETER LIU, WHO LEFT
A HUGE MARK ON BROADWAY AFTER HE
THREW HIMSELF OFF THE ROOF
OF THE WINTER GARDEN THEATER
PROTESTING.
HERSCHEL WILLIAMS, HE BECAME A
WRITER.
HIS FIRST BROOK, "FRIEND OF THE
DEVIL, GROWING UP WITH THE
RACHEL FINSTER," WAS A BEST
SELLER.
TIME TOOK US ALL IN DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS.
FOR A BRIEF MOMENT, WE WERE
ALL THERE TOGETHER DANCING THE
NIGHT AWAY WITH OUR WHOLE LIVES
AHEAD OF US.
EXCEPT FOR ME.
I WAS MURDERED BY RACHEL
FINSTER, AND MY SOUL CANNOT
CROSS OVER UNTIL SHE IS BROUGHT
TO JUSTICE.